welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and what if I told you that Nicholas J
Fury has been lying to you how would you
feel if I told you that from the moment
he stepped foot in Marvel's secret
Invasion that he's been tricking every
single person around him with a very
convincing lie the LIE of the limp but
most importantly I am so glad that
secret invasion is finally here after
all these years be sure to tune in to
new rockstars every Wednesday for our
secret Invasion breakdowns and even more
secret Invasion discussion on our newest
channel the break room the show is
filled with conspiracies research walls
and even more crazy details and we'll be
breaking it all down on new rock stars
and the break room and of course you can
grab some of our awesome secret Invasion
inspired merch over at nerd riot.shop to
let people know that you are not a
scroll that's right but those
shape-shifting allegations to rest by
going to nerd riot.shop today but
anyways unless you are faking an ear
injury you heard me correctly okay Nick
Fury has been faking a leg injury this
entire time but don't worry he's not
trying to commit insurance fraud like
the rest of us I believe Nick Fury has
been pretending to be a man in need of
orthopedic surgery specifically because
of this one-man War he is about to wage
against a shape-shifting race who have
been living amongst Humanity for decades
to put it simply Nick Fury's leg is bait
by limping around in secret Invasion
Nick Fury is executing one of the most
classic and effective Espionage
techniques in the Spy game known as a
canary trap now if you don't already
know what a canary trap is basically
it's a spy practice of spreading false
information to specific people around
you that you suspect to secretly be an
enemy undercover agent and then waiting
for that false information to get leaked
and make its way higher up your enemies
chain of command but how could a
technique like that help Nick Fury at
this point in his life you may be
wondering well to be honest secret
Invasion would be the best time for the
world's top spy to implement this famous
spy technique against graphic and his
hidden scroll Invasion specifically
because it makes hidden scrolls with
human faces expose their true
allegiances and looks like graphic
Scrolls fell into Nick Fury's Canary
trap pretty much immediately in episode
1. Fury is in town Jay is he a man says
it's nothing to worry about he's
Watchdog walks with the limp can barely
seal the good eye like right away during
the very first scene that we are
introduced to graphic Pagan informs his
leader immediately about this piece of
Intel about Nick Fury's bad leg and also
tells him that one of their Scrolls on
the inside gave him said Intel ladies
and gentlemen the canary trap has
already been sprung literally how did
Pagan know that Nicholas J Fury was
walking around with a lift because if
you look at the way Nick Fury walks
around in that entire episode of secret
Invasion his limp barely manifests at
all and he appears to specifically make
an effort to hide said limp this means
that the only person that Nick Fury
actively showed his limb to before Pagan
tells graphic about it was none other
than his right hand homie Maria Hill
that's right everybody I believe that
Maria hill was a scroll the entire time
in that first first episode of secret
Invasion that she has purposely been
feeding information from Fury back to
graphic specifically so graphic knows
how to manipulate Nick Fury and Taylor's
best a scroll Maria Hill is the only way
Pagan could have gotten that information
because she fell right into Nick Fury's
Canary trap now all Nick Fury has to do
is wait until he finds out that graphic
knows about his bad leg then think back
on the very small list of people that he
showed his imaginary vulnerability to
and that's how you catch a scroll baby
listen gang your enjoyment of Marvel's
secret Invasion will not be complete if
you do not watch inside Marvel on new
Rockstar's new channel the break room
yes I will miss being on inside Marvel
dearly but all of my amazing friends
will be answering all the burning
questions after each episode and will
stop at nothing to uncover all the
Scrolls of the MCU on the break room
you'll see all the new Rockstar spaces
that you've come to love as well as
friends of the channel new and old and
celebrity guests will be legally
obligated to make appearances like there
are some up there already for real gold
for yourself join us for every episode
of secret Invasion as we pour over all
the evidence to figure out who is and
who isn't a scroll and if you don't want
to miss a single clue subscribe over at
youtube.com breakroom NR we can also
potentially see this scroll Maria Hill
at work as Nick Fury Talos and her
listen in on Sonya fallsworth private
conversation speculating on where the
Scrolls could get their bomb for the big
Unity day explosion the immediate threat
Remains the bombs five specialists in
Moscow are capable of building such an
explosive my mind is on this one
Vaseline Corporation former kitchen
Rebel owns a high-end Gallery in the
citizen then the scene directly after
this moment suspiciously shows Pagan
assigning Gaia on a mission to meet the
same person that Sonja fallsworth
mentioned in the recording now while
most people would think that Sonia
fallsworth was just coincidentally right
on the money with the exact mysterious
entity that the squirrels could get
their bomb from I think that this is
very unlikely considering that Sonja
fallsworth only lists tested one out of
a possible five entities that could have
constructed the bomb so realistically
there was only a twenty percent chance
of Sonia being right however Nick Fury
and Talos were coincidentally exactly on
the money and found a scroll
impersonating proprician at his place of
work while also being coincidentally too
late to stop Gaia from acquiring the
bombs from propression before them I
have a feeling that right after Sonia
named proprician as someone who was good
at making bombs this fake Maria Hill
sent that Intel back to Pagan like she
did with Nick Fury's leg and intercepted
the real bomb maker before Gaia even got
there and a scroll Maria Hill could also
serve to explain why Nick Fury saw all
those squirrels at Unity day
impersonating people that he saw
previously in the episode like that rude
guy from the bar that both her and Nick
Fury went to or that woman or the little
girl that he spent a good while
awkwardly staring at after telling the
fake Maria Hill that he was about to go
take a walk in Russia while black very
interesting choice Nick Fury since she
knew that he was about to go on this
walk the scroll Maria Hill was probably
stalking him close by before Sonya
fallsworth mediocre bagman stole Fury
away but most importantly if Maria hill
was a scroll during the entire course of
the first episode this means that she
was probably planted there by graphic to
fake her own death to make Fury feel a
massive amount of guilt because you
gotta remember if they have the body of
Maria Hill then they have Maria Hill's
memories of her helping Nick Fury fake
his death in Captain America too so they
would be able to fake a fake Maria
Hill's death in this situation but at
any rate graphic doesn't seem to want to
kill Fury at Unity day or else he would
have just shot him along with this Maria
Hill the goal appears to be to make Nick
Fury suffer and him thinking that Maria
Hill died because of him would do that I
would suffer if I was new Fury the point
is Nick Fury has spent three decades
spending time amongst the scroll people
and learning the techniques that they
use to infiltrate planets and live in
hiding and although Nick Fury can't
detect a scroll with his eyeballs his
years of experience with these Scrolls
taught him how to make a scroll reveal
their own to himself especially since
the squirrels don't have the luxury of
having all of Nick Fury's years of
experience as the earth's greatest spot
this is why I strongly feel that Nick
Fury's Canary trap of a bad leg is about
to catch every single one of these enemy
Scrolls by surprise once they realize
that they've been had but other than
finding out squirrels another big reason
why Nick Fury would want to fake his leg
injury is primarily because he has
resolved to fight this battle against
the skrulls completely alone and even
tells Roadie as much after Roadie
suggests to call The Avengers maybe we
should call our friends no we can't jump
the gun on that you know the next thing
you know they find themselves duplicated
and turned into terrorists this is my
War Brody like Nick Fury is the greatest
and most feared human spy on the planet
and he knows it because this dangerous
man is fighting this battle alone Fury
does not want his enemies to be on high
alert and be so worried about what he is
going to do next by giving his enemies
the false idea that he can barely walk
this allows them to underestimate Nick
Fury and rejoice that Humanity's
greatest protector could barely beat
them to the mailbox anymore this gives
dick Fury so much more space to move and
work freely and face far less resistance
Nick Fury faking this limp is truly the
perfect spy technique to execute for
secret Invasion like this dude's a
genius but anyways thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me at mastertonment on Twitter if
you guys want to see me tweet some weird
really fun secret Invasion theories
I'm like all over secret version on my
Twitter but most importantly please
support our growing network with a
secret Invasion shirt at nerdriot.shop
these shirts are amazing and you will
look amazing in them so go to
nerdrive.shop today and if you like live
discussions debates and reactions to the
titles that you love be sure to
subscribe to our live Channel thebreak
room don't forget to hit that Bell so
you can be notified when we have some
more analysis to offer because we love
analyzing things for you guys we're big
old nerds but anyways thank you guys so
much for watching again love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys later bye
[Music]
thank you